what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so a lot of the guys really really seem
to enjoy the whole idea of injustice
origins running over the origin story of
some of the newer characters even some
of the established characters and
injustice granted really a couple in it
earlier with Brainiac and Atrocitus but
um in truth I was really just trying to
find a way to kind of keep in justice
relevant on my channel while we were
waiting for you know the actual comic to
start the first story arc to finish and
so on and so forth so again uh what
we're going to do here is we're going to
cover the origin of reverse-flash eobard
thawne just because of the fact that at
the time I'm recording this video I feel
like it's going to be earbuds on it
might not be and if it's not we'll do
the origin story of the person who is
actually you know actually is the
reverse-flash but I have a hard time
believing it wouldn't be here Bard
thought just because of the fact that
he's the most iconic person to hold the
mantle of reverse-flash slash professors
in so because of this there's a little
bit of context that I want to throw in
here and what this does is it comes out
of a story called the return of Barry
Allen keep in mind Barry Allen and
basically died during crisis on Infinite
Earths but DC had set the stage for
Barry Allen returning at some point
along the line because he was just kind
of appear from from the speedforce
speak to you know Wally West or somebody
sometimes as a disembodied voice
sometimes as an illusion or a physical
being but then he would just go right
back into the speedforce again and that
would basically be the end of him um all
indications from DC was that Wally West
is now the flash and it will stay that
way until some future point in time so
with the story the return of Barry Allen
this is one of those who basically
turned everybody's head and the reason
why is because of the fact that people
still liked the idea of Barry Allen a
lot of people who are picking up with
the flash Wally West were curious about
Barry Allen but in their mind Wally West
was the only flash they wanted and so
what happened over the course of the
story is that he was revealed this is
not actually Barry Allen this is eobard
thawne now Thawne had appeared before
crisis on Infinite Earths and he had his
own stories of different things like
that but post-crisis keep in mind DC was
revitalizing its landscape and so what
they did is they revitalized the origin
of eobard thawne now he did get a new
origin in the new 52 but this particular
story has been done in so many ways it's
been done on the flash TV show it's been
done in animated movies and so because
of that I feel like or maybe it's been
hinted at in animated movies but I feel
like this origin is so iconic for eobard
thawne it would really be the only
reasonable one to use so because of this
what this does is
basically led to a cat-and-mouse game
between Wally West and eobard thawne as
Wally was beginning to pick up the clues
and realize that Barry Allen was not
very alland it was actually eobard
thawne and so what the two of them
basically meeting for this final
showdown what is happening as eobard
begins to go through what his origin
story is and what he does is he
basically tells Wally that he hails from
the from the 25th century and the 25th
century as eobard thawne describes it is
both a place of enlightenment but it's
also a place that's not welcoming for
individuals who cherish the idea of
superheroes now the reason behind this
is not because superheroes are looks
down on it's nothing like that it's
simply because of the fact that there's
no need for superheroes anymore that you
know the various agencies that you know
help maintain peace across the globe do
so using technology and so the idea of
Batman is no longer necessary Superman
is presumably long since left a lot of
the people who are traditional
superheroes as we think of them are no
longer part of the equation because
again there's no need for them but from
the perspective of eobard thawne this is
his torment this is his prison he is one
of a handful of individuals who look to
the idea of heroes and what they stood
for and believed that heroes were one of
the greatest things to exist and so
because of that like a lot of scholars
and so on and so forth eobard thawne was
obsessed with heroes specifically he was
obsessed with the flash he was obsessed
with them in such an extreme degree that
his idea was to basically find a way to
meet Barry Allen one day now what Mark
Waid is doing here with regard to this
little bit of a story he's essentially
telling us that eobard thawne's
obsession with Barry Allen borders on
the realm of insanity and in fact he
even undergoes you know this more
essentially surgery basically to make
himself look like a Barry Allen so that
shows you how extreme he was willing to
go he's the ultimate fanboy more or less
but what ended up happening here is he
would be basically took a kind of
historical journalist historical text a
sources journal for the flash and
intended to take it into the past and
then turn around and you know have Barry
Allen sign it the problem with this was
that accessing the past was a very
difficult thing to do it was almost
impossible until he found an artifact
that would allow him to time-travel and
so because this his dream had become
reality you know it was like going to a
convention and being able to meet like
every single one of you guys it's just
like this is amazing I mean it's
something that
you hope to do one day but it's
virtually impossible and so because of
that eobard thawne being able to meet
really his his idol in a lot of
different ways what's an opportunity
that he shouldn't I couldn't simply let
go now something to keep in mind here is
that this bit of origin basically
intertwined with with eobard thawne
fighting off and on with wally west so
there's much kind of funny because
eobard thawne overpowers wally west in
the worst way it's crazy like wally west
just does not have the ability to go
against ear Bart Thawne but this is kind
of a stepping stone to Wally West
becoming a greater flash becoming faster
than Barry Allen was becoming more
capable than Barry Allen was just
because of the fact that eobard thawne
as he exists now has all the same powers
that Barry Allen had before he died
during crisis on Infinite Earths so it's
really kind of a comparison kind of a
you know where does Wally West and in
comparison to where Barry Allen was and
it just shows you how much more powerful
Barry Allen was than Wally West but the
fact remains here the the next step in
eobard thawne's plan is to basically
duplicate the powers of the flash now
the funny thing about this is that with
regards to e of our Thawne when flash
initially gained its powers it was just
you know being bathed in some chemicals
and struck by lightning and that is the
formula that eobard thawne uses in order
to give himself the powers of the flash
but I want you to keep this in the back
of your head because as we progress
through this what will actually do is
will reference Geoff Johns flash rebirth
and the length that that eobard thawne
went to to actually make Barry Allen the
flash to ensure that eobard thawne's
history or I guess his future actually
comes into existence but because of the
fact that the only way to use the cosmic
treadmill to basically transition back
and forth through time was to have the
power of the Speed Force or the power of
the flash that's exactly what a abides
dawn did he gave himself the power of
Barry Allen now jumping into the past
itself
what eobard thawne does is he describes
this as extremely rigorous and extremely
mind-numbing and almost driving him
insane and it's interesting because of
the fact that whenever people usually
travel back and forth through time
unless you talk about like time trapper
or something like that it's not
something that DC delves with on the
regular you don't routinely see people
traveling back and forth through time
and DC the way do you see with like
Marvel Comics with Marvel Comics people
like cable just jump back and forth your
time as if it's nothing I just kind of
do it on a regular basis you know Bishop
does it on a regular basis now because
of that Marvel has gotten time to have
at least the principles of how a person
Tom travels and colleagues down to a tee
marvel's problem is continuity and cable
is a retconning
he literally just exists to go back and
change things in the past that's all he
does it's his his cable is a weird guy
when it comes to counter books but it's
not your mains here that with with what
he worked on transitioning back into the
past his mind is in an altered state not
necessarily that he is a real high on
the experience or anything like that but
he's in a very fragile state he's
literally walking a knife's edge between
sanity and insanity to have a problem
with this is that when he travels into
the past he travels in the past in the
post-crisis landscape now this begs some
questions
this really asked you know requires us
to ask a few questions if crisis on
Infinite Earths was an event they
basically existed to eliminate the
multiverse and reset DC's continuity
then does that mean that eobard thawne
actually did go back to the point when
crisis on Infinite Earths happened but
because crisis happened he effectively
hit a wall he couldn't travel back any
further you know so it's like safe
points or something like that froze the
guys who played video games you know
what crisis on Infinite Earths it
basically said no one can travel before
this event took place
so eobard thawne's set the calculations
right get everything he was supposed to
but basically hit a wall of continuity
and couldn't travel back to meet Barry
Allen before the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths
because of the fact of the multiverse
and all time had basically been reset so
again I kind of asked a few questions
here and there and really Markway
doesn't ask us these questions in the
comics it's just something that I happen
to think about and saying the same does
seem sort of interesting but in order to
keep the intr of getting wildly
complicated we're not going to invoke
crisis on Infinite Earths any further
aside forever saying why there's a very
ounce dead but what is up happening here
is eobard thawne this is actually a
really funny moment here
eobard thawne in his little skirmish
with wally west while he's telling Wally
his origin well he basically grabs an
object and tries to throw it and eobard
thawne t-boz fun whips around NOK said
you know and actually a way and says
don't do that again
and that's a really cool loan I really
really love that's one of things I loved
about eobard thawne's character there's
so much arrogance so much hubris feel
but so much power and he's just he's
just cool man like I think he of our
Thorne is so cool that's what I'm really
hoping he comes back in the flash TV
show because he's one of my favorite
characters but getting back into the
story what ended up happening here is
that eobard thawne walking a knife's
edge began to see him slipping down the
path of madness
and the reason why is because instead of
being logical and reasonable as his
intelligence and as his wealth dictated
wounded up happening is he basically
said well the reason why I'm he
or in the post-crisis landscape when you
know baryons already dead is because
state led me here fate wants me to be
the new flash state wants me to take
over the role of Barry Allen now
honestly this is just wishful thinking I
mean oh that's really all that is it's
if eobard thawne taking what he wishes
were true and making it true of course
we know Wally West is the flash but when
ISM happening is that because eobard
thawne takes this mission onto
themselves it comes to believe that he's
the guy who's supposed to take up the
mantle of Barry Allen what we end up
finding out here is that he begins
transitioning through the different
history all the different villains of
Barry Allen learning everything he can
about them what their strengths are what
their weaknesses are using his
intelligence to benefit him as he
analyzes these individual guys only to
stumble across the most dangerous foe of
Barry Allen who's revealed to be eobard
thawne himself now this is when his mind
fractures this is when his mind
basically got Shenzhen tumbling down the
rabbit hole and what ends up happening
here is eobard thawne basically begins
to realize that if he's destined to be
the bad guy if he's destined to be the
most formidable foe of a very Island
then basically he can run away from his
past he can run away from who he is and
he can make himself Barry Allen now the
ironic thing about this is that in an
effort to keep from becoming professor
zoom becoming you know reverse flash he
makes himself reverse-flash
he's literally living out the actions
that lead to him becoming the
reverse-flash and that's one of the
reasons why time travel in DC DC Comics
is a little more grounded because it
basically asks the question if you see a
future event take place and you travel
into the past to keep that future event
from happening is your time travel in
all your subsequent actions the reason
why better then happen in the first
place so I guess it's a little more
grounded DC's a little more controlled
when it comes to the idea of time travel
but the fact remains here but this
really just kind of gives us the origin
real quick just in the sense that
because of the fact that eobard thawne
adopted the mantle of Barry Allen he
basically went forward as Barry Hamlin
which was basically the story the return
of Barry Allen now eventually um he was
you know he regained his normal self he
realized who he was he basically kind of
accepted his fate but he was destined to
be the villain of Barry Allen and that
was it that was really you know the
origin story of him going forward within
the realm of DC Comics in the
post-crisis of a diverse landscape now
something else what I want to point out
here is keep in mind this is the main DC
Comics this is not the injustice
universe like we said in the the
Brainiac video
we said in the Atrocitus video the idea
is to basically grab the origins from
these different characters and then see
whether or not you know if they'll match
up with injustice just because of the
fact that injustice routinely does not
really cover origins and justice just
gives us those characters so again I
want you guys to have a reasonable idea
of where these guys are healing from and
what these guys stories are about but if
you guys are new here to come and
explain this you guys with the sub
button to become part of the world
course you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah by the way
please stop making memes out of me
people are making memes out of me like
is it's not cool guys alright I don't
like being turned into Power Girl
alright stop turning me into memes and I
will catch you guys later peace
[Music]
you